Senator Richard Durbin is trying to pass
a bill we go back we call him Dick
Durbin because yeah Dick Durbin this is
an Illinois Senator bro this is you know
how how famous is it he's got a
he's got an existing nickname
so that no like uh Richard is that's the
nickname for Richard yeah but like yeah
we call him yeah because in when he ran
I mean it's much like vote for Dick
Durbin you know it's pretty Dick Durbin
yeah I'll just say that Illinois and
Chicago some of the most corrupt
politicians and politics to have ever
existed in America so we stand by that
yeah so he's trying to pass this bill
which is Bill s4090 it would add a
regulation which wouldn't allow any
supplement to be sold without meeting
expensive regulation criteria
um and the question from the video that
I had sent you was
um what does he have to gain from this
is he invested in some pharmaceutical
companies right can you explain for the
people that don't understand can you
explain what the process is for getting
a supplement out into the world at the
moment as far as I'm concerned there
really is not much that needs to be done
like almost at all I'm pretty sure
um
I don't know if you have to register
with the FDA even
um and because there is an FDA bylaw I
remember looking into this at some point
um where like they don't have the right
to uh like basically audit your product
and make sure that you're selling
whatever you're selling so yeah this law
seems pretty pretty good well that's the
thing I mean it seems pretty good but
I'll say this who stands to win and it's
that's why I dislike it I was I was
leaning towards let's not do this
um we talked extensively about how Tick
Tock is making children's brains into
gray matter okay that's much more scary
than some bodybuilder selling some you
know sketchy uh supplement products to a
small amount of people when you know I I
personally don't like seeing
pharmaceutical pharmaceutical companies
and and big companies winning especially
when a small business can do it the
right way we know people who own small
supplement business and they take a lot
of pride in the product that they make
they would not be able to sell these
products they would not be able to have
a business if this thing went through
and that's what I'm concerned with so
I'm leaning towards saying Dick
Durbin uh on this one dick
dick on this I I I thought but I mean
it's interesting to think about both
sides right like yeah regulation could
be kind of cool because you could be
consuming poison well I said when you
brought it up to me this morning before
we went to the gym as you swallowed down
two scoops of completely untested random
powder mixed in water you and Dylan are
just having this proprietary blend and
like horse hair and bull semen and
whatever it is like how toes and stuff
and that's what you that's what you're
taking that being said
um you guys in the bodybuilding
community large generally has a soft
spot for
a guy with a large bathtub and a ton of
meth and he sprinkles a bit of the meth
into a pre-workout and then you get to
use it this is Jack 3D this is what's
that what's the labs that makes crack
oh so that yeah so crack is not even
that has uh
dimethyl or something it's dmaa is what
we call it dmaa that's what that's what
was in the old Jack 3D formula uh and
that is a banned substance now 15 years
later re-released yes but you have to
buy it on eBay basically yeah um look we
have a soft spot right for that because
it's like fun you know and we're
responsible like we we know one of the
guys who I think is like the top
mind around supplements in Derrick yeah
and like we are responsible consumers
obviously teenage kids uh who go and get
sketchy internet drugged so that they
can work out harder that's not a good
thing you know right so I mean look at
uh Logan Paul's Prime man that's got 200
milligrams of caffeine and it's being
drank by 11 year olds it's being drank
by kids that weigh one third of your
body size yeah that's the Wild Thing
This is and I'm gonna go on a bit of a
tangent here okay because I do think
there is a caffeine consumption uh like
epidemic in America
um I remember asking this woman what she
drank this morning she said I had a
venti cold bro which is uh venti cold
brew and I like looked it up as
something like 250 milligrams caffeine
she's 125 pounds okay she's like yeah
I'll probably get another calf or
probably get another coffee
um at 3 P.M now there is some science
that talks about athletic performance
around uh caffeine use and it could be
anywhere from I mean there's clinical
dosage of like actual improvements in
athletic performance it's three to
sometimes even nine 9 milligrams per
kilogram of body weight so being a
hundred kilo male you can take 300 to
almost 900 milligrams and it sounds
crazy right but we're talking about
athletic performance here we're not
talking about a buzz so you can go to
your marketing job Susie okay so we have
there's absolutely a caffeine degeneracy
and I definitely feed into it okay I
totally understand that but uh it's it's
something that that definitely needs to
be talked about but I what something I
want to say is Red Bull was the of like
was the first like okay let's get
caffeine remember that and people used
to hate Red Bull for that reason and
then there was Red Bull vodkas which
started to happen I remember it was all
over the news saying don't drink Red
Bull VOD because it's an upper and a
downer it's killing you all this
right now we have drinks I don't know
how much is in a Red Bull eighty a
hundred uh one small camp the small can
yeah maybe one twenty one fifty I think
it's 150. that's nothing bro that's a
walk in the Park especially for
Susie she's gotta have two of those okay
so it just the line just keeps changing
another thing too man the um
what's the martini espresso martini
okay we used to complain about uh Red
Bull vodkas and now people are obsessed
with espresso martinis hey you're
doubling the Red Bull vodka
sweetheart you think you're being all
cutesy because it's in a different glass
that's just caffeine and straight
alcohol going right into you
okay
[Laughter]
that's my rant and I'm sticking with it
I gotta talk about this it's intake it's
a fair take man but I think when it
comes to the the supplement thing
the concern that you would have from
everybody's side that doesn't want
legislation is if the only way that
companies can make stuff like a
multivitamin or a greens powder or a
creatine or whatever is to go through
this very expensive process you're then
going to raise up the price because that
needs to be passed down to the consumer
these companies aren't going to make
products for nothing so first off you
push a ton of small companies out which
reduces competition which means that
companies can then that remain in the
market can then charge more they can
also need to charge more because of the
increased cost they've had to go through
in order to get this pop product
regulated
and that means that the customers end up
paying more that being said are there
concerns I have pretty big concerns
about the fact that you can me and you
can go out to the garden and just
create a random list of ingredients and
go now it's a supplement hide it behind
proprietary blend yeah and it's just
this pixie dust thing and we can create
a Cool brand and start selling it of
course that that that is a concern uh
and I don't really know what the
solution is neither of those worlds seem
particularly great to me yeah I'm I'm I
agree with you I agree with you even
though it seems as though I'm like
staunchly on one side I totally agree
with you I I do think though I'm leaning
uh away from the regulation
I would agree I don't think that I'm
down for regulation longer term what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]